[Music]
hello i'm nick croatia you're watching
sky news tonight with a special program
as the government unveils its new policy
for asylum seekers crossing the english
channel the headlines
destination rwanda the prime minister
defends his multi-million pound scheme
to send asylum seekers 4 000 miles away
these vile people smugglers are abusing
the vulnerable
and turning the channel into a watery
graveyard
sky news takes a first look at where
refugees will stay when they arrive in
rwanda
the prime minister puts the navy in
command of the english channel but will
it deter people from attempting the
cross
this doesn't make sense
they're welcoming all ukrainian people
like they're humans we're humans as well
[Music]
hello good evening thank you for joining
us asylum seekers who attempt to reach
uk shores illegally will be sent 4 000
miles away to rwanda to be processed the
prime minister has put the royal navy in
control of the english channel and
defended his new multi-million pound
policy as the right thing to do but the
new plan has received criticism from
migration and human rights charities you
say the measures are draconian and
lacking in compassion coming up this
hour we our panel will be answering your
questions on the new policy first though
let's take a look at these new policies
that have been announced by the prime
minister
anyone who entered the uk illegally from
the 1st of january this year may now be
flown 4 000 miles to rwanda
from today the royal navy has taken over
operational command in the channel from
the border force
while boris johnson has said the 120
million pound deal with rwanda is
uncapped and the country has the
capacity to resettle tens of thousands
of people in the years ahead our first
report tonight is from sky's lisa
holland who's been examining the details
of the government's asylum plan
they waved to our cameras delighted to
be in uk waters
we tracked the same group to the beach
in the kent town of lid how's your
journey today sir
the migrants know they will be met by
the emergency services and medical help
if it's needed
it is this process which the prime
minister has vowed to break through
deterrence
promising to send tens of thousands of
male and female asylum seekers to rwanda
for processing or a new life
we must first ensure that the only route
to asylum
to in the uk is a safe and legal one and
that those who try to jump the queue or
abuse our system
will find no automatic path to
settlement in our country exactly as
boris johnson was speaking in dover a
baby was amongst the migrants brought
ashore at the port
in future the government wants to screen
those arriving through an illegal route
and via a safe country such as france
i think we need to see these plans for
what they are it's a desperate
announcement by a prime minister who
just wants to distract from his own law
breaking you know they're unworkable
they're extortionate they're going to
cost taxpayers billions of pounds
with predictions there could soon be a
thousand migrants arriving by small boat
a day the navy and the army have now
been drafted in
but the strategy to tackle the rising
numbers is hugely controversial still to
get through the commons and likely to be
challenged legally
i've seen nothing that provides any
reassurance that people's human rights
are going to be upheld parliament has
been considering the government's
legislation that would allow it to move
forward for this with this plan
for the past few months and the house of
lords has put up huge opposition
for those who remain in the uk a former
raf base in north yorkshire will be
turned into a new reception center with
more than a hundred thousand asylum
seekers there's an accommodation
shortage
five million pounds a day is being spent
on hotel bills alone the government says
the system is broken in birmingham we
met fider from afghanistan who's been
waiting two years for his claim to be
processed he says even the asylum
seekers themselves aren't happy
asylum system is too long for us
long process no give me money no house
no clothes no shoes in the same wide
tent not helping the daughter yeah
someone in the mentally problem
the prime minister says his plan will
save people from the greed and dangers
of people smugglers but the fact is
everything else to stop the channel
crossings has failed lisa holland sky
news
well an initial 120 million pounds is
expected to be given to the rwandan
government under a trial scheme after
the home secretary struck a deal during
a visit to the capital kigali in a joint
news conference with the country's
foreign minister to confirm the plans
pretty patel said rwanda had a history
of resettling refugees in a skilled way
skies shanghi marieke is traveling with
the home secretary and has had a first
glimpse of a new asylum center in the
country's capital from there he sent
this report on rwanda's refugee camps
over 4 000 miles away and on another
continent but here was a home secretary
arriving to unveil a plan that places
rwanda at the heart of our immigration
policy
her proposal to punch a one-way ticket
to east africa for people who reach the
uk illegally an agreement she hopes will
deter people from dangerous journeys
like channel crossings
they'll stay in accommodation like this
block
here the government says they'll have
their asylum claims processed before
taking steps to rebuild their lives
potentially in rwanda
this used to be a hostel but it's
already being prepared for the arrival
of asylum seekers from the uk there are
50 rooms in this block including places
to eat and sleep but essentially it's a
holding center where those people will
wait for their asylum claims to be
processed
pretty patel was confident that building
and this country will be a safe space
australia set up their own offshore
processing system and there are reports
of
self-harming and even people taking
their own lives because these people are
going through
tremendously difficult times with their
mental health and they've made a
difficult journey i wanted to just ask
how will you ensure the well-being of
asylum seekers sent to rwanda do you see
that as a uk government's responsibility
or are you passing the buck australia is
not comparable this is not the type of
arrangement that australia had australia
as a sovereign country obviously had its
own arrangement
it is fair to say
our teams have been working through
facilities here you've heard me mention
in my opening remarks as well the
technical experience that we are
bringing we believe in investing in
rwanda we're very open about that
rwanda's foreign minister feels they are
ready to process thousands
we assess our capacity to
receive
migrants and we know that we have
a capacity in place to
to receive migrants
to reach that point though they'll need
to scale up fast
here they're planning to build two more
blocks
on top of that politicians don't want to
deal with a british backlog
if our kids rwanda's kid has not the
possibility to go at school because of
the poverty
how around the government
we assume
to
to give education to the kids of these
refugees
on the streets of kogali we found a
sense of hospitality rather than
hostility
we can encourage all of the world to
come to stay in rwanda they may be
called immigrants or whatever they are
just
people
for many who make the perilous journey
for a better life places like this will
now be the ultimate destination but the
debate around whether the decision is
right has only just begun shingi
maharike sky news kikardi
and shiggy joins us live now from the
rwandan capital good to see you so we
saw this center the big question is will
rwanda be able to cope with an influx of
potentially tens of thousands eventually
arriving
good evening it's an interesting
question that and we had the chance to
go and see
the sort of accommodation that asylum
seekers will be staying in earlier on
today as we saw in that piece and it's
perfectly reasonable space that it's got
room for a hundred people there's a
communal dining area there are places to
sleep and there will apparently be
specialists on site to help the people
make those adjustments but what i found
really interesting were the questions
that the officials there could not
answer we spoke to them a bit about the
development itself it's meant to be a
block one block in a set of three we
asked when the other two blocks would be
built they couldn't tell us that in fact
we then later found out that the rwandan
government hadn't even finished buying
that block of accommodation from a
private company so there are lots of
questions about what happens when
british people get asylum seekers from
britain get here and we also had the
chance to watch pretty patel unveil this
plan alongside a rwandan minister and
she talked through it at length quite
bullishly despite the fact there are
other questions about the cost per head
for each person coming here we know that
there's a 120 million pound price tag
placed on this scheme but we don't know
about how much it will cost for each
person and we don't have a we don't have
a further breakdown on that front either
but despite all of those things she was
confident she spoke to us after the
press conference and told us that she
wants thousands of people to come here
and not only that but that she wants to
expand the scheme to other countries so
even though it's a controversial policy
it's one that the government are
doubling down on
all right many thanks indeed
well the new plans have received
criticism from migration and human
rights charities who say the measures
are draconian and lacking in compassion
and that they won't work they have been
questioning why it's necessary to send
asylum seekers thousands of miles away
for processing wisconsin haranak has
been to calais to find out whether the
new measures will actually deter people
from attempting the crossing
she sent this report on the people there
seeking asylum
shafi's journey to dunkirk started in
afghanistan he fled as the taliban moved
in until a few weeks ago was in ukraine
but war once again forced him out
this is now his temporary home
as you can see like it's a rough
situation in here
this is the you know every day they
bring the water in here
here you take the bod so as you can see
there are families there are kids all
over here
they're waiting like thousands before
them for a chance to take the final leap
into new futures
but their dreams are being rewritten by
the uk government
news that we broke to them
if they take us to africa what are we
gonna do there there is no future for us
in africa we are from afghanistan i was
trying to become a translator so from
there you know from the taliban took
over the country so our life was in
danger with their determination
unfaltered their intentions remain
they'll keep trying to get across till
they succeed we still have to go like we
can stay in this country since we don't
know anyone here you know
everyone thinks about their future so in
england everyone like they give proper
rights to the human beings
they wait weeks and months for
opportunities like this last october we
watched around 80 people board
inflatable dinghies in broad daylight
all of them made it across the channel
for years the uk and the french
governments have been battling to stem
the flow of asylum seekers arriving at
camps like these but this is a business
a form of organized crime a network of
people across the world preying on human
misery and a desire to get to the uk
the home office plans are said to be
directed at young men like shafi but
they say the timing is callous
this doesn't make sense they're
welcoming all ukrainian people like
they're humans we're humans as well
there shouldn't be double standard in
the world the war has been started from
since 20th century in afghanistan
and they are suffering too much and now
in ukraine this is just started and
everyone is just thinking about
ukrainian people this is not fair for us
the european commission has slammed the
new policy as neither humane nor
dignified and for those a whisker away
from new beginnings this is no deterrent
just another hurdle to overcome
ashna harinag sky news in calais
let's take a closer look then at how
this scheme is going to work
pretty patel the home secretary has said
that eligibility for the scheme will be
based on in admissibility to the asylum
system suggesting it will apply to
people whose claims for asylum in the uk
have already been rejected
all transfer requests by the uk will
require approval by rwanda before
relocation so rwanda can effectively
veto any cases at their discretion
exact financial arrangements for the
scheme haven't yet been set though the
refugee council has estimated the plans
could cost 1.4 billion pounds a year and
what is also unclear is whether the
policy will only affect unaccompanied
adult men or if families women and
children could also be eligible for
deportation well let's get the thoughts
of our political correspondent rob
powell one thing unclear there there
seems tonight to be plenty that isn't
very clear not least the cost of all
this yeah exactly because that 120
million pounds that's been flaunted by
the government today is actually just
investment in rwanda's economy as part
of this partnership it's not really
anything to do with the practical
elements of this scheme you set out
there that one and a half billion was
the figure put on it by the refugee um
council we're told by the home office
this evening that there's no further
information about figures put on
compensation um for the scheme we also
don't really know and i think this is
what shingi was getting at when he was
questioning pretty patel and kigali
what the involvement of the uk and
rwandan authorities is going to be we're
told that the decision on the asylum
claim in rwanda is made by the rwandan
government because it relates to staying
in rwanda these people won't be won't be
taken back to the uk if they're approved
this is about settling and building a
life from rwanda but to what extent does
the uk have oversight over what is going
on in these accommodation units and how
the service is being run we don't really
know who exactly will go there was a
lack of clarity this morning after some
briefing that it would mainly be single
men um we're now told
it will be everyone but not children and
minors
and families won't be split up which
suggests mainly single men and single
women but of course rwanda can say no
if they are worried about say criminal
records we don't know whether this is
completely legally sound lawyers have
been pointing out today that there may
be legal challenges um using the refugee
convention using the european convention
on human rights as well boris johnson
said as much in his speech that he
expected there to be legal challenge as
well and i guess the big thing we don't
know is whether it will work this has
been tried in a few countries um before
it hasn't always worked when it's been
tried there in australia there was
reports
of people um self-harming because of the
conditions in there but i think there's
a political imperative for the
government to do something i think they
think this will be popular in terms of
it shows they're taking it seriously but
i guess the real measure of success will
be how many people build lives in rwanda
successfully and whether it stops people
making that perilous crossing across the
channel plenty of questions though
tonight thanks a lot rob
now coming up later this hour we're
going to be joined by a panel of experts
who'll be answering your questions on
this new asylum plan do send your
questions to us by email at news sky dot
com or you can tweet them to us at sky
news
now uh the latest on this asylum plan
bound to feature heavily in tomorrow's
papers we'll have our extended press
preview and news review from 10 30 this
evening with tonight's news and
tomorrow's headlines joining us will be
assistant comment editor of the
telegraph olivia utley and the political
editor of wales online ruth masalski
you're watching sky news tonight thank
you for your company coming up we'll be
speaking to an immigration lawyer about
the government's plans to send some
asylum seekers thousands of miles away
to
[Music]
the plan is to take the political
temperature midweek so we'll be
discussing the biggest stories of the
week so far talking about what's still
to come having a look at prime
minister's questions of course and
getting reaction from politicians plus
our very own viewers and we'll have
analysis from my sky news colleagues the
take with sophie ridge on sky news
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ukrainian government is confirming that
they are now engaged with russia's
soldiers
air raid sirens fill the airways in the
distance artillery rains down it feels
very close to the center of
there's one they found this devastation
to their apartment
lots of people live here quite a few of
the windows of the houses have been
blown out by the blast
and it feels that it's changing each day
[Music]
[Music]
b
[Music]
let's get more now on the government's
plans for some asylum seekers crossing
the english channel to be flown around 4
000 miles away to rwanda the prime
minister says the partnership will be
fully compliant with international legal
obligations and has insisted that rwanda
is globally recognized for its record of
welcoming and integrating migrants in
his words well joining us now is an
immigration lawyer harjap singh bangle
good to see you on sky news tonight
thank you for your time i mean when you
first heard this that
plans to send them to east africa
what do you think
i just thought instantly will hold on
costs unworkable it's not moral
um you know is this the right thing to
do
elections looming
um boris johnson and rishi sunak in
trouble at the moment probably holding
their worst ratings ever and is this
just something to take the pressure off
them that's what was my initial thoughts
and when i started looking at how it's
going to work and the costings of it and
the previous models it's going to be
based on like australian system and what
the israelis did in rwanda then i sort
of realized well hold on the money being
touted around is definitely not going to
be enough and that this is going to cost
the british public a lot of money for
potentially what's going to end up as a
disaster like pretty much else the home
office has been doing recently why would
it be a disaster
because if you look at the home office's
record first of all on stuff like
windrush look at it on how the ukrainian
scheme was started
what it does is it announces stuff but
it hasn't got the infrastructure to deal
with this so it's announced this it's
not going to announce how the staffing
is going to work
how many people are going to be sent to
this center i mean the british public
tonight are probably thinking 20 000
people a year are going to be sent to
this center but australia last year only
managed to process 250 people offshore
and it cost them 460 million pounds
to do so so 120 million
isn't going to cut it for 500 people
isn't going to cut it for a thousand
people
and also the whole thing about boris
johnson's today saying well hold on they
won't be allowed back they're expected
to settle in rwanda israel did a similar
thing for three years
and managed to send 3 000 people to
rwanda out of which only nine are there
today
and who are living in dire straits the
rest have been snapped up by the gangs
and have been uh migrated elsewhere and
some of them might even
be here so the gangs are always a step
ahead it's almost as if the
the people are being punished as opposed
to the gangs being punished there's no
announcement on providing lifetime
sentences for gangs how we're going to
catch the gangs or and you know well
yeah he has pledged though hasn't he to
to to give life terms to uh people
traffickers i want to go into the the
legal side of this now but boris johnson
has said that he does expect legal
challenges what avenues can people
pursue when they hear this
yeah of course they can put in human
rights claims and if they're going to be
sent to places where it's degrading for
them and if there's no proper facilities
if it's equivalent to torture i a lot of
detention centers and even one in the uk
has been closed recently uh because it
was inhumane and it was awful the
inspector who went round there said it
was you know it was the conditions were
terrible no human could live there so
they had to close it down if the
conditions are going to be similar then
of course there's challenges in there
you can't say we're going to process
asylum seekers and then have them worse
often from the places where they've come
from so that is going to be an issue and
the challenge also boris johnson's very
cleverly covered himself because he
might be realizing the hold on what
we're trying to do is essentially
unlawful and so therefore i'll inform
the public well hold on there's going to
be challenges to this it's a bit like
the equivalent of say
a news corporation let's say tomorrow's
saying we're going to sack everyone but
we expect to be have some tribunal um
you know uh hearings about it well of
course because what you're doing
essentially is breaking the law so if
you break the law you're going to be
challenged and lawyers are there to make
sure the law is
pursued and applied correctly to
everybody and we you know recently we've
seen how the government treats the law
and the government breaks his own laws
so yeah you don't know yet but you don't
know that people are going to be worse
off now
or then than they are now do you these
assurances from rwanda that
these centers or the one that we've seen
today will be safe and and it welcomes
people
yeah i mean rwanda is going to be
getting paid for this so obviously
that's why they're doing it of course
they're going to say yeah sen send it
over they're going to be earning money
out of this but we don't know anything
about the original conditions the way
they've dealt with the people sent from
israel
hasn't been brilliant because otherwise
they would have stayed there and settled
there so we don't really know and until
you know we're shown that it's safe and
until we've shown that it's proper no
one is going to believe it and
essentially the key is nick where's the
money for this going to be coming from
if we're going to say right we're going
to build a detention center with top
quality standards and you know it's
going to be safe and everything then
what about the staffing who's going to
pay them where's the money going to come
from i've already told you how much for
three for 250 people the australians are
paying 416 million we're going to run
into billions like this over the last 10
years australia spent 5 billion pounds
and have decided that it's better to use
the pushback system for the boats rather
than process people offshore because
they just haven't got the numbers all
right
i'm afraid we'll have to leave their
time is is against us but i'm sure we'll
talk too much more about this
in the coming days and weeks thanks a
lot
thank you
okay let's take a look at the weather
for you shall we
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now it's turning warmer but there'll be
rain or showers at times and a mostly
fine evening but rather foggy near some
southwestern coasts while ireland
northern ireland and northern scotland
will be quite cloudy with patchy rain in
the north and west most places will stay
fine overnight but ireland and southern
and western britain will see low cloud
and fog returning ireland can expect a
little more rain too but it will be
mostly dry elsewhere the uk will see
sunny spells developing widely friday
morning but exposed northeastern and
southwestern coast will stay rather
great elsewhere inland parts of ireland
will see fog low cloud and patchy
drizzle giving way to brighter skies and
scattering showers northern ireland
though staying quite dull
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good to see you on sky news tonight
coming up we'll be hosting a special q a
on the government's announcement that it
plans to send some asylum seekers to
rwanda
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome back asylum seekers who
attempt to reach uk shores illegally
will be sent 4 000 miles away to rwanda
to be processed the prime minister has
put the royal navy in control of the
english channel from today and defended
his new multi-million pound policy as
the right thing to do however the new
plan has received criticism from
migration and human rights charities who
say the measures are draconian and
lacking in compassion well you have been
sending in your questions to our guest
panel and we will put those too our
guest joining us is dr noor al-haq
nasimi a former refugee and founder of
the charity afghanistan and central
asian association which helps refugees
in london to integrate we're also joined
tonight by the labour peer and former
refugee lord dubs a very good evening to
you both thank you for your time today
let's uh let's crack on with these
questions uh shall we um let's start
with manish who
thinks uk policy towards migrants has
been hostile for many years but so many
people still attempt he says the
treacherous crossing he says the
government does need to put up a very
strong deterrent but asks if this scheme
is the solution as it does seem quite
expensive and in his words inhumane
uh lord dobbs let's start with you um
what's the answer is it correct
no of course it's not it's it's a
mistaken policy it goes against the
united nations high commissioner for
refugees principles it goes against the
1951 geneva convention it sends people
away to a distant country with no
assurance that they'll have legal
support or any of the rights that they
ought to have in a civilized country so
i i don't accept what the government is
saying nor do i believe that rwanda has
a good human rights record
that's that's also
being questioned so i think it's a
mistaken policy and i don't believe the
government has any authority to do it uh
i don't think we've got any legislation
to do it the nationality and borders
bill is still going through parliament
there's an amendment to do with offshore
offshoring and and and that's gone back
from the lords to the commons so we
haven't even finished yet uh doctor do
you see me um expensive and inhumane
this scheme
uh i think we need to find
a form of wards that addresses the
universal concerns
uh for this uh plan
uh we have to remember there was a
a race in
a recent history there was a serious
genocide
in rwanda and one has a very poor track
record on
human rights
uh i i completely uh agree with your
honorable guest that this is a serious
mistake and i think that the government
should provide
a proper
maybe debate in the house of parliament
as well as uh asking the british people
the british people and the public uh to
see what is
the views of the british people what
british people
are
telling us whether we should
continue we should go ahead with this
plan or not
let's move on to a question from david
now who asks how a democratic government
can even contemplate such a scheme he
asks how will the plan affect the
reputation of the uk on the
international stage and does it not
involve breaches of human rights lord
dubs
well well i i agree with what the
question is saying
yes uh
i think our normally good tradition of
respect for human rights over many years
has really been trashed by this
government
they've been doing it for some time now
but it's got even worse this is a
terrible decision it's a decision which
says we don't want people in this
country we want to get rid of them
whatever their rights should be and i
don't think i don't think we're going to
be regarded other than very badly by the
international community for having
neglected our responsibilities and
neglected our traditions
okay um
dr nasimi how will the uk
be regarded on the international stage
then
we have to understand that uk
historically
is the most democratic society in the
world and the most
hospitable society in the world
but on the other hand
uh
taking such a decision is it seems
irrational
according to the
views of the many people i was watching
the news today and i was reading
also the views of the british people
in different newspaper and most of the
british people they say this is a wrong
decision i do understand
the aim of the prime minister
who which
discourage
the traffickers
to smuggle people
and put their life
in dangerous
and also encourage
to find
the the safe the safe way the safe
the way that how people they can travel
in a proper way to the united kingdom
but on the other hand i see that
rwanda
ruled
by a
dictator and and we have many uh
refugees who came for asylum from rwanda
in the united kingdom
we'll stay with you dr nasimi here's a
question from peter who says is if the
government is prepared to fly these
illegal immigrants to rwanda for
resettlement why don't they just fly
them back to their country of origin i
mean that might happen anyway if rwanda
doesn't approve them
dog's going to see me
oh
sorry it wasn't okay and basically and
this questioner asks peter says why
don't they just fly them back to their
country of origin if the government is
prepared to fly these illegal immigrants
to rwanda for resettlement why not just
send them back in the first place rwanda
might do that anyway
i think
we have a
dublin convention which said that
anyone who claimed for asylum
uh
in the united kingdom
uh
the human rights their human rights
should be respected and the authorities
do not have the right to
deport them back to a country where they
come from for example the people from
afghanistan who are coming to the united
kingdom everyone knows that they are not
economic migrants they are coming to a
from afghanistan to the united kingdom
because of prosecution they escaped the
war they escaped the taliban and the
taliban
as you know that their human rights
record also is very
bad
and that's why i think that we need to
also
consider the dublin convention
to see that whether the dublin
convention allowing
the united kingdom to deport people back
to
to their own countries or not but let me
go to lord dubs but we are running out
of time on this section so let me ask
you one more question lord dub so you
can come back on this john thinks this
is a really good plan but says it should
also include those migrants who arrived
illegally last year he asked some
lawyers will try to challenge this
scheme so how can the government prevent
them from slowing it down or even
stopping it all together we we know
don't we that this scheme at the moment
will affect people or should affect
people who've come to this country from
january the first onwards this year
lord dubs this one you're using a word
which which doesn't apply you're saying
illegal
human beings fleeing for safety are not
illegal if they cost a frontier they're
not illegal if they're seeking to get
safety and we shouldn't be calling them
illegal what what's happening is that
they are not traveling by routes which
the government wants them to follow but
the government has made it almost
impossible to follow follow what they
call legal routes
anybody wanting safety player flees
across the frontier to get to
to find uh to find where there's no
persecution and to get out of ukraine to
get out of afghanistan to get out of
syria you've got to you've got to flee
across another another frontier and the
government are simply finding a way of
saying we don't want you here at all
it's not right it's against human
traditions it's against the geneva
convention it's quite long and the word
illegal should not be used about human
beings in that way
um
is that
your understanding dr nasimi in just
an answer if you would on this specific
question uh what is an illegal crossing
so uh
according to the
refugee
situation when you look at
in the history uh normally the people
who are
uh leaving persecution or leaving their
countries to find a safe place most of
them they travel without passport
without any documentation because
they can't
apply for a visa and they can't get a
visa how they can
consider as a
illegal migrants of course this is the
only way people they can find a safe
place
for themselves and for the for their
family members
is to take us a long journey a very
painful journey and and
eventually arrive in a country where
they can feel
safe and better i don't uh i disagree
with the term
used illegal migrants
all right well thank you very much
indeed gentlemen for now we'll be back
to you in a few minutes in the meantime
you're watching sky news tonight with a
special q a on the government's asylum
plan in a few minutes we will be asking
how will the navy enforce this policy
and make sure certainly try to make sure
that no votes make it to the uk
[Music]
i'm inzamam rasheed and
north of england correspondent telling
stories from this culturally rich region
i call home
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
they say they can't go back to myanmar
yet if they do they fear their weakness
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
if there is a bigger explosion this area
would be in the danger zone
these traffic jams snakes for hours up
and down this hillside
we know that 800 000 people have been
displaced
i think experiencing the 2 million
person march in hong kong
that was a moment
[Applause]
[Music]
police have been firing tear gas and
rubber bullets
see fires all around us here siobhan
robbins sky news bangkok
i'm john and i'm sky news's west of
england correspondent
from fishing communities to bustling
cities we spend every day reporting from
across the region
hello welcome back you're watching sky
news tonight with a special q a on the
government's new immigration plan
joining us again is dr noor al-haq
nasimi a former refugee and founder of
the charity afghanistan and central
asian association which helps refugees
in london to integrate were also joined
by the labour peer and former refugee
lord dubs and also in this section kevin
saunders the former chief immigration
officer for uk border force in calais
who was present at boris johnson's
speech today welcome to you all thank
you for joining us so some more
questions then let's start with shah
who's looking at the financial
implications of
the news scheme she asks is it more cost
effective for the uk to send illegal
migrants to rwanda than keep them in the
country and why is britain a destination
people head for rather than anywhere
else uh let's bring in uh
our uh former border force official
thank you for joining us let me put that
to you because um you were there today
but nothing came out about the cost did
it 120 million pounds going to rwanda
but this is specifically for the economy
nobody has a clue how much this scheme
will cost
no um all we know is what it's costing
at the moment
and it's costing us five million pounds
a day
that's every day seven days a week
to accommodate um
these people uh in hotels in the uk
so
um
you know that that that's a lot of money
i i have heard a figure of 120 million
for set up costs
whether that's true or not i don't i
don't know
lord dubs that 120 million figure is
going straight to the rwandan economy so
really are you concerned about the cost
no but this is a an open book isn't it
well because of course i'm concerned
about the cost but because it is
taxpayers money and it is not being not
being used for good for good purposes uh
so uh i mean there was one conservative
mp who said who said yesterday i think
that it would be cheaper to keep people
in the ritz than to send them to rwanda
now that may have been a political the
political rhetoric but the fact is that
we we don't know enough about the stream
as a whole we've had this thruster at us
the home sector has not explained in
detail how it's going to work
has not explained in detail what happens
if somebody is refused refugee status in
rwanda what happens now they sent are
they flown back or what have you and the
other question that was asked is
why why the attraction of the uk look i
believe we should share responsibility
for refugees across europe we can't take
them all we should take our share that's
oh that is my only my only plea and why
some of them want to come to the uk it's
quite often family reasons i've talked
to afghan boys who fled the taliban
before the borders were closed
they've made their way to calais and
they want to join family members in
britain what is more sensible and humane
than that we should agree that if an
afghan boy wants to join a family member
in his country that he should be able to
do so that's simple it's straightforward
it's humane
let me put that to dr nasimi briefly all
about compassion isn't it as lord dubs
is suggesting there and family reasons
yes of course as i said that
in my
previous
conversation the reason people they
choose britain because of its democratic
values because of its
hospitality because of the opportunities
available in the united kingdom
but on the other hand thinking when my
colleague was talking about
this uh 120 million pound
uh that the government will spend i was
thinking why the united kingdom
do not set up expect they do not spend
this money to set up an immigration
center
in the united kingdom to keep them here
rather than
sending these people to rwanda with that
without their wishes with their will or
with their uh
expectation because so i don't think
that the people
who
uh put their life in risk to come to the
united kingdom where then
will be
sending to
rwanda all right let's move on a
question from a viewer who would like to
remain anonymous uh at the moment they
asked operational control of the english
channel has been handed to the royal
navy
right now how will they enforce this and
make sure no boats make it to the uk a
question for you then kevin saunders
yeah um
first of all i am extremely glad that
the royal navy have taken over
control of the channel um
they're going to bring commander control
to
the situation
they're going to be deploying
uh drones they're going to be deploying
uh aircraft helicopters
all of which is going to assist in
looking down
onto the channel to see
what's happening down there where and
where it's uh
what where people are trying to get on
boats and obviously we can let the
french know so they can do something
about it
um and if they uh
if they are coming across the channel
then we can then intercept them but
but what we what we're doing
the idea of this legislation
um the prime min what the prime minister
said this morning
was we want to deter these people from
coming across the channel um
i know that the the there will be an
objection if i call them illegal
immigrants but i want to call them that
to distinguish between them
and the other migrants that are coming
to the uk
um
like ukrainians hong kong chinese and
and afghans
um
we've got to remember that we have taken
185 000 people
through our various schemes into the uk
what we're trying to do is to stop the
illegal
arrival of these people
we're saying to them if you come
illegally if you don't come properly
then we are not going to deal with you
now there is nobody forcing them into
these boats
they are getting into the boats for
their own free will and i would pose
this question to you
would you
pay a
smuggler
10 000 pounds or 20 000 pounds or
whatever it is to get into a boat
to know that when you reach the uk
you're going to be put on the plane so
rwanda and the answer to that is no you
wouldn't and this is what we hope will
will happen and we hope that these
people
won't make these dangerous crossings and
will claim asylum in one of the many
european countries which are perfectly
safe which they've traveled through
let's move on because we haven't got a
lot of time here's another question jan
says the plan seems to be very confused
and it isn't clear where illegal
migrants in jan's words will end up once
they have been processed in rwanda she
asks does it mean they can't apply for
asylum in the uk once they have gone to
rwanda if so does that break
international law uh lord dubs let me
put that to you this is these are our
viewers people putting questions
describe them as illegal immigrants or
illegal migrants and and that that is
the thrust of it and
i know i appreciate you saying uh you
have difficulty with the word illegal
but people are posing these kind of
questions
the problem is if there are no legal
paths to safety
then people in desperation will go any
way they possibly can and what this
government has done is to close legal
routes to safety if i if i take the case
of children who are stuck in cali want
to join their families here
there used to be a method when we're in
the eu under the dublin treaty where
whereby they could a child in one eu
country could apply to join relatives
and others so a syrian boy in in kelly
could apply to join an uncle and say
birmingham well that's all be closed
down by the government so if there are
no legal routes to safety they have to
find whatever way they do and i just
don't believe this i don't believe this
will work and i think it is wrong in
principle uh you know and and and and i
i think we're on we're on the wrong side
of where we should be the united nations
high commissioner for refugees they
don't like this uh the geneva convention
talks about people being able to claim
asylum uh wherever they can and i don't
i don't think i don't think we were on
the right path here at all what's more i
doubt whether the home sector has the
legal powers to do it the legislation
hasn't gone through yet it hasn't been
debated in parliament we have to have a
proper democratic process for debating
it to see what it actually adds up to we
don't know yet okay a couple of final
thoughts dr nasimi um we are running out
of time do you think this scheme will
get off the ground
you see we have many large countries
within the european
communities
and the question is why the other
european countries which my colleagues
say that which are very safe and
and
having much much greater than rwanda why
they don't accept this refugees in the
first instance for example in norway in
sweden in germany and in france i think
that they're
there
maybe the united kingdom they should put
more pressure on other european
countries including on france of not uh
complying with the
uh
uk agreement that there was a number of
uh
important
agreement made by the between the united
kingdom and the french authorities for
the past maybe 15 years but the french
authorities they are i think they are
not very transparent
in
complying with those
agreements
okay let me come in there i apologize we
have uh running out of time very quickly
one one word kevin saunders will this
scheme get off the ground
yes
uh lord doug
you you don't think it'll happen
the government will try and make it
happen but i don't think it's gonna work
no okay gentlemen i do appreciate uh all
your time tonight thank you so much for
joining us here on sky news tonight
thank you
thank you thank you
thank you
easter coming up let's have a look at
the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
and just in time for the bank holiday it
is turning warmer but there will be rain
or showers at times a mostly fine
evening but it will be